le président de huawei richard you
dévoile en grande pompe le nouveau
téléphone 5g du géant des
télécommunications chinois un écran
pliable qui se transforme en tablette de
8 pouces carrés une grande rapidité de
connexion avec le mec x20 web
impressionné c'est un peu comme si on
passait d'un boyau d'arrosage au niveau
de la capacité annonce d' incendies donc
beaucoup plus de données beaucoup plus
vite beaucoup plus de performances avec
moins de latence ou away ce n'est pas
seulement de la téléphonie mobile
c'est d'abord un fournisseur d'antennes
4g et 5g pour le compte des opérateurs
mobiles un marché à l'échelle de la
planète
d'ailleurs le fournisseur chinois
équipés la principauté de monaco qui est
devenu le premier état d'europe
entièrement couvert par le réseau 5g au
mois de mai un décret américain a obligé
les entreprises américaines comme google
à rompre leurs relations avec
l'entreprise chinoise la plaçant sur une
liste noire et l'accusant de menacer la
sécurité nationale
l'enjeu sécuritaire a aussi poussé la
france à adopter une loi communément
appelée loi huawei et l'exigent l'aval
du premier ministre avant le déploiement
de nouveaux équipements et au canada la
5g est encore au stade expérimental
aucun ado je pense qu'on attend de
s'aligner sur les américains pour leur
décision évidemment on veut faciliter
les échanges commerciaux avec les
américains il ya l'aspect stratégique
qui est toujours à déterminer si on est
partenaire avec les américains et les
américains interdisent le 5 g de huawei
ça devient délicat dans n'utiliser le
numéro deux mondial des
télécommunications ne compte pas
s'arrêter là
il lancera cet été des téléviseurs
intelligents équipés de son propre
système d'exploitation
ici à smic rails at radio canada
montréal